[Rires]
des lingettes de voitures
je suis en train de faire
il y a un filtre mais c'est le filtre
Michael Jackson Michael a mis son visage
non non non non
le problème c'est que c'est consternant
il y a rien d'autre à dire oui mais ça
concernant et c'est pour ça que les gens
regardent mais c'est pour ça que les
gens sont les réseaux assure des gens
comme ça c'est pour voir leur quotidien
qui est certes alors
on n'est pas obligé d'assister non plus
hein
ce genre de contenu mais c'est
incroyable soyons sérieux 30 secondes tu
peux pas
caution c'est juste
que c'était pas plus intéressant
[Applaudissements]
de l'avoir fait pipi comme ça
moi j'aurais fait mon prénom
à débat
voilà franchement
elle est content
je pense qu'elle est angoissant je vous
dis je pense qu'elle est le premier
degrés avec l'ananas
entre la bouche et le cerveau et en fait
non mais il y a plus de filtre c'est pas
méchant en fait elle pense un truc et
elle le dit
c'est une télé comme ça je ne l'assume
pas les gens veulent pas voir la piste
en même temps il y a une forme de
naïveté
quand même je vois pas l'intérêt de
passer dingue et même pour elle je sais
pas quel ce qu'elle pense d'elle-même
enfin de faire pipi Benjamin est-ce
qu'on pourrait poser la question voilà à
Monsieur Verdez j'aimerais bien
l'entendre
c'est lui qui m'attend
avec plaisir alors qu'en penses de ce
merdes et bien Nicolas non moi je suis
pas du tout scandalisé
sa vie c'est de se filmer sa film
également quand elle fait pipi
faire pipi dans la neige n'est pas un
scandale même si c'est dans un parc
naturel islandais moi j'ai fait pipi
même pire dans la neige je me filme pas
ça va pas déclencher un séisme donc
laissez-la tranquille laissez-la pisser
tranquille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé parce que à la rigueur
faire pipi que n'importe où ça on l'a
tous fait un jour mais de là à se fumer
moi j'adore ma veste très sympathique
mais de là déjà
certains jeunes pardon
c'était plus intéressant la la la la la
[Applaudissements]
vous avez des enfants par exemple oui
est-ce qu'ils sont pas ils sont fans de
madagasaden
après moi je trouve ça totalement
ridicule voilà maintenant effectivement
je c'est ce qui se passe de plus en plus
sur les réseaux voilà se filmer à faire
n'importe quoi mais je crois pas
honnêtement je la connais pas mais je
crois pas que elle est pensé à mal pour
faire le buzz voilà
honnêtement
je vous le dis quand même comme ça au
coin du bois je crois que la fille de
Cyril l'aime beaucoup
alors je vous jure allez
elle est très gentille mais de la filmer
en train de pisser
en train de chier naturel
dit que ça ce qu'on voit c'est
effectivement ce que les jeunes
recherchent en fait non mais en fait en
fait c'est ce qu'on donne aux jeunes et
à force de normaliser ça on crée une
génération qui aura toujours toujours
plus loin et qui n'a absolument plus de
fond et c'est et c'est vraiment très
triste
un peu légère tu es le problème de faire
pipi dans une réserve naturelle c'est
pas ça le problème c'est qu'elle parlait
de la fameuse lingette et à mon avis
elle n'a pas remis dans la poche sa
lingette
[Applaudissements]